peut-être une communication d'un autre
genre notre invité de ce soir le premier
ministre
jean castex bonsoir monsieur le premier
ministre bonsoir samuel jean castex
invités de samuel etienne sur la plate
forme des jeunes twitch ou emmanuel
macron qui demande à 2 youtuber star
mcfly et carlito de faire une vidéo sur
les gestes barrières fait une vidéo pour
expliquer ses gestes et si vous avez 10
millions détournés à l'élite capter
l'attention des jeunes c'est vieux comme
le monde
en politique on valéry giscard d'estaing
l'avait déjà compris en 1974 il abaisse
l'âge légal de la majorité de 21 à 18
ans le jeune devient un enjeu électoral
c'est un témoignage de confiance dans la
capacité de la jeunesse française
le vote à 18 ans qu'est ce que vous en
pensez personnellement je trouve que
c'est une bonne chose cela me permettra
de voter la prochaine fois prochaines
élections et peut-être que cela
transformera les résultats des jeunes
qui pourrait changer les résultats alors
il faut les séduire exemple en 1985
françois mitterrand fait le pari
audacieux du par les jeunes
vous êtes un président chébran vous
savez ce que c'est que chébran pour
sauvez moi quand j'étais enfant déjà on
a versé le l'ordre des syllabes dans le
no1 pas très nouveau ça doit pas ce que
ça veut dire branches et bien entendu je
vais pas faire la belle mais mal
informés c'est déjà un peu dépassé un
loyer du dircab les et câble et un autre
l'a été tout autant jacques chirac en 87
un nom avant l'élection présidentielle
travaille son image d'homme cool
jacques chirac a bien changé branchez
rajeuni groupies de madonna il multiplie
les interviews en destination des jeunes
une transformation progressive c'est sa
fille qui lui choisit ses chemises et
ses pantalons
elle lui rend sa liberté que pour le
choix des chaussées mais parfois ça ne
fonctionne pas en 2005 jacques chirac
toujours se prête pour la première fois
un exercice compliqué en direct face à
des jeunes ils arguments pour le
référendum sur la constitution
européenne
deux heures des échanges qui se solde
par cette phrase
et ce qui me fait encore plus de peine
c'est le pessimisme et je vais vous dire
très franchement je ne le comprends pas
et ça me fait de la peine
l'incompréhension un rendez vous manqué
avec la jeunesse et parfois à trop
vouloir être cool on frôle le ridicule
comme cette partie de beer pong dans un
pub parisien prétexte à boire pour
étudiants fêtards erreur de
communication reconnaîtra son entourage
séduire les jeunes
exercice périlleux en politique mais
indispensable à quelques mois d'une
élection
[Musique]